Cleveland Indians closer Andrew Miller
here on the show how are you Andrew
I'm doing well there well so what was
that experience like for you I mean
that's that's like boyhood dream type
stuff right yeah exactly I think never
would have dreamt a chance to
participate in these uh you know being
an event like this is so much fun and
it's neat to share a locker room with
these guys and you know just kind of rub
shoulders with them but the fact that I
got in there and got to you know close
out a game and I'm credited with a save
it is pretty hard to beat so a lot of
fun and you know glad I got invited and
you know glad it worked out this way so
let's let's stick in in the actual
moment of from last night first before
moving on with you Andrew
so what what what are you doing in that
bullpen when you know it's going to
extra innings you're just waiting to see
if you're did you know at the time that
you'd be just saved until the moment
that could hopefully rise for the
American League yeah I mean they kind of
filled me and I was mostly expecting to
kind of come in and clean up an inning
but for everybody to watch the game it
was so well pitched that that an
opportunity never really arose so I was
out there and you know Kimball went in
did his job and I know I had the next
inning so once that happened I was going
to be a lot of fun and then obviously to
no hit that Homer and just get me
opportunity owned and protect a lead and
that situation was uh you know a special
moment and you know thankfully I had
some pretty good defenders behind me
made the inning open your foot yet did
it a blast to be a part of and just you
know really really fun experience did
the phone ring as soon as Cano's ball
left the yard yeah no we'd already kind
of schedule it out that's the one thing
about these games everything's a little
bit more mapped out than the usual you
know regular season you know with your
team type situation so a little bit more
of a heads-up than usual not everybody
out there panicking one or two the phone
calls for it was so a little bit less
stressful in that regard Andrew Miller
the man who saved the all-star game
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
yeah I mean that's true you save the
game you save the game for the American
League so you were in the all-star game
last year and this year biggest
difference obviously is last year the
home-field advantage for the American
League was on the line and this year was
not which one do you prefer I think I
prefer the new form
or I guess you could call it the old
format we're going back to you know just
purely exhibition and I think you know
you could certainly watch it certainly I
can feel as out there guys want to run
to the motions those national league
hitters wanted to win the game obviously
just enough to catch you wanted to win
the game so the players still cared I
think we put a good product on the field
and as much as nice as it was to have
Corey Kluber win the game last year and
give us Game seven at home I think the
right thing to do is to reward the team
with the better regular-season record
didn't you know let them have that
home-field advantage and something
that's so important as opposed to you
know an all-star game deciding that so I
like the new current format and you know
I think that the product certainly it
wasn't a lackadaisical game guys seemed
to really care and be invested in the
outcome so there was no difference in
intensity you didn't notice any
difference in desire and want to win
from last year to this year I didn't see
anything for me it was such a different
experience that it was a little bit more
relaxed and comfortable this go-around
it's not it's not the easiest situation
I think it's a it's pretty overwhelming
at least for myself and kind of trust in
the situations with you know between the
media coverage and just being around you
know such great players it's a it's
probably something that you know wears
you down a little bit and you know
hopefully gets a little bit easier every
time I would trade it for the world but
it's a little direct certainly a
pressure packed event you know from our
perspective but it's uh you know I think
that you know from what I could tell the
product on the field the way guys were
playing the way guys were taking the
bets it's been to the game they weren't
throwing away and trying to get home
that's for sure and I was thinking about
it Andrew Miller Indians reliever here
former Yankee on the Rich Eisen show was
that the first time you threw to Gary
Sanchez or was he up before you got
traded away last year you know I I'm
sure I threw him in spring training he
was not up in a major leagues no I think
that you know right around when they
made that deal I think a couple of those
guys came up last year so I missed him
in you know the major leagues last year
but he was definitely in camp with us
and I'm sure I threw at least some sides
it's not some spring training games to
him but you know he's you know as well
known for his bat he's a pretty darn
good catcher and he had that reputation
over there it's fun to you know see
familiar faces I came to the game it was
almost nice to have somebody at least a
little bit of familiar but
and they kind of smile and go over what
we're going to do and then go out there
attack the hitters so when you hear
people sing and I'm going to raise my
hand say one of them I'm a baseball
purist so I'll watch any of these
all-star games and it is the most of any
sport Andrew the most the this all-star
game of any sport resembles an actual
game regular season or postseason than
any of the other ones I mean none of the
football doesn't come close basketball
doesn't come close but when you hear
people say that I'd like to see more
runs scored in the all-star game what
are the pitchers think when they hear
that pitchers never once he runs scored
you know I think that you absolutely
want the fans to really love it I agree
with you I think we do have the best you
know all-star game out of any of the
league's I think we're going to put on a
pretty good show and you know I would
think this year was just a well pitched
game I think that these guys were locked
in it seemed like you know certainly the
game went on the intensity of the events
probably picked up a little bit not hey
we get it we're pitchers that we know
homeruns are exciting and you know big
swings of the bat but you know if you
act like you can't appreciate Justin
Upton diving and you know Francisco
Lindor coming across to the oldest field
and so on across their body to make big
plays and you know the abets that gosh
that they put together I kind of went in
there and thinking all right everybody
wants to be here it's going to try to
hold on and they spit on pretty much
every pitch I threw so if you can't
appreciate that kind of baseball I think
that you need to look a little bit
harder what do you think of the idea
that Bryce Harper forwarded that the
vote leading vote-getters in each league
would be the ones to pick the teams so
you you could be you could be throwing
your teammate in an all-star game what
do you think about that idea it's
interest now I'm glad people care enough
to throw ideas out there I heard that
and then you know maybe a world versus
us type setup or something like that was
thrown out thrown around a little bit
this year but you know I think maybe I'm
a little old school and a little
attached to the American League
personally set up but you know if
there's a way you can do it maybe even
you know not every year but you know mix
it up a little bit if that's what gets
fans to to tune in and it makes game
over a little bit more interesting yeah
it's worth at least discussing a couple
of more minutes with the man who saved
the all-star game last night for the
American League Andrew Miller of the
Cleveland Indians here on the Rich Eisen
show how was Terry Francona how's you
doing I think he's doing well yeah we
you know we missed some where we're
getting updates
pretty much just like your belts I think
they're doing a good job to pass
information along I think you know
everybody you know certainly cares about
and wants them to get better so you know
we're looking forward to having back in
Oakland it sounds like you know they
addressed whatever the issue was and you
know most importantly I think you know
he needs to get his health taken care of
just you know we love him and that's the
most important thing for him at this
time but best you can tell he's going to
be back as your skipper Friday as far as
I know I think he's planning on it and
you know who knows whether that's him
talking to doctors answered I can't
imagine a patient in the world and
everything he can to get back to us and
he cares about us so much that you know
he's probably not always you know making
the best decisions for him when it comes
to that but not my expectations he'll be
back pretty soon
has there been a World Series hangover
the loss and lingering effect because
you know you guys are have been somewhat
inconsistent I think that's fair to say
of seven games over 500 is nothing to
sneeze at two and a half game lead I
understand but what about this team's
second half chances Andrew yeah I mean I
think we can be a better team I don't
think there's a hangover in the sense
there's certain doubts pieces being paid
you know we I don't think we would trade
you know the experience we had last year
for the world and you know if anybody's
tired or anybody's you know struggling
because last year we're not hearing it I
think everybody did a good job taking
care of themselves and all season and
did a good job in spring training trying
to you know maybe adjust pitchers
workloads and that kind of thing but you
know I think we're just we can play
better baseball than we have and you
know like you said worse we're still in
pretty good position here the Royals are
playing really well the divisions kind
of cluster tightly Minnesota's you know
got a couple you know pitchers that are
having incredible years and they're
doing a good job right now so you know
I'd like to think that you know we can
play better baseball inside class and
take care of business and you know we
wish would have played better in the
first after I think everybody can say
that even the teams that are out the big
leagues would like to have won a few
more games at the end of the day you
know we're lucky it's 162 game season
and we get a chance to show that over
the rest of these a couple of more
questions for you Andrew Miller the
pitch clock sure sounds like it's coming
the that was a talk at the all-star game
in Miami
what are your thoughts on that subject
you know I don't love the idea that
doesn't mean it's not going to work out
I think you know it's you know we
already have the clock now it's been
introduced
slowly with between eating setup and you
know that hasn't been a problem with
anything it's kind of nice to think
everybody's kind of adjusted you know
when replay was added to baseball it was
kind of thought of as blasphemy it's
turned out pretty good it's taken a
while to kind of fine tune it to where
we want it I'm not a fan of the idea of
the pitch count pitch clock I think that
you know as you know batters and
pitchers all we can be better about
being quicker and making making the game
task flow better but you know in a big
moment you know that when the the
pitcher and catcher up to talk or go
into a bunch of signs and it's important
you know moment of the season even I
think that that drama is actually
increased with a little bit of extra
time and maybe you lose some of that but
you know mostly things tend to work out
I wish you know players were listened to
a little bit more I know that you know
the way rules can be put in put on the
books is basically they can ask us to do
it we can say no and then the next year
they can do it you know laterally on
baseball side so it sounds like that
sort of the direction Rob wants to go
but you know I hope that works out
because you know we want the best
product we want the best game when you
put out there last one for you I'm sure
you work obviously we weren't watching
the broadcast you're out there in the
bullpen
Bryce Harper was miked up and conversing
with Joe Buck during the action during
the live action and at one point
Bryce Harper asked Joe Buck how dak
Prescott was going to do this year if
you were miked up and in the same
situation would you have asked Joe Buck
how Blake bortles is going to do this
year would that have been your question
as a football and Jaguar fan I don't I
don't know if that's what my mind would
that's a pretty impulsive before I would
be thinking about you know his football
team or whatever I don't know is he a
cowboy Sam somehow I guess he's from
Vegas I don't I've never heard him make
a in NFL allegiance announcement of any
sort I remember yeah well you know I
don't know if that's where my mind would
have been but yeah I guess look America
to check in on what the Jags are looking
forward to this year I think a little
too much hype last year in expectations
hopefully the the the corner is being
turned though I know
Coughlin's back around at some capacity
so news that were infected floridays we
got to be fired up about for net right
running the football for jet for jackal
I you know they've been raving about the
draft picks for years I'm looking for
more click and really take off and
hopefully you know Fallon will be back
and all these different things so you
know I think you know
it sounds like they're going the right
direction or just waiting for it all to
come together Andrew thanks for taking
the time I know this is your time off
after a busy all-star week and you're
going to make your way to Oakland with
the American League Central leading
Indians always appreciate you calling it
thank you yeah absolutely thanks for
having you got it as Andrew Miller the
Rich Eisen shown weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to move week six games to
Saturday for that wedding you have to go
to